Oh welcome my name is paratah it's been
84 years since we have played this game
welcome to the graveyard
my name is nany nany TT fanny
good job hits really nailed the name ah
my back my legs all the memes were right
I shouldn't have skipped leg day god
damn it
oh boy here we go up give it a little
skip oh my god
seriously are we gonna walk this [ __ ]
slow you bros suggested this game all
right
I mean I'm sure my god we're going to
visit Edgar the faith I got really
[ __ ] tired after I'd go to the eighth
but after I got the faith I was like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] I'm not having another
one is this it are we gonna go I better
take a break and sit on that bench
because I'm so well look at the graphics
back in my day we didn't have advanced
tree dad for graphic like this oh let's
sit down I am not only old but also
senile great
perhaps we'll walk I can look at myself
now oh [ __ ] we got old saggy tits and
[ __ ] hey Perry pies apple pie I'm such a
big fat prick oh okay fine should we go
insight I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm
doing you can't see me [ __ ] try and
find me never find me Oh Here I am
how do I sit down I mean why am I
playing this game why you walk with her
to the bench in front of the chapel you
turn her around and let her oh you got
to turn around to sit down man how did I
not get that
my butt is so boney here we go here we
go come on yeah don't look at me don't
look at me don't look at me no why do
you know what's how may when you are
done you walk with her back to the game
okay oh I guess I better go
I wore my best outfit for this video I
hope I'll get a lot of subs now in space
tube now that no one uses YouTube
anymore this is the final walk of
burning power I will confront the devil
himself the black beast Edgar
now I will pay the price for all those
YouTube subscribers for an eternity in
heaven with that Edgar son of a [ __ ] oh
god oh god this oh [ __ ] is the
apocalypse is coming it's coming it's
coming
what not even a [ __ ] screen just
quitter research who would press restart
who in the right mind would press
restart let's press Start missed a
really important detail all right you
know what [ __ ] this alright we missed an
important detail in this game now we're
hardcore gamers on this channel and if
we're gonna play a game we're gonna do
it right alright so here we go again I
once said this game is boring as [ __ ] I
don't know where you get your ideas from
kids these days are so used to
explosions and FPS is Call of Duty they
can't appreciate a game about playing as
an old lady in black and white that
moves wave too [ __ ] slow almost there
we're almost there we got to get to the
bench and then we something is gonna
happen at the bench come on granny my
back hurts
oh it's every time I hear it it's so
beautiful okay what language is it it's
Dutch grammar
you smell like you poured the whole
bottle all over yourself oh I take no
responsibility for what happens to
Grandma
she died on her own free will is she
dead she's sleeping she's sleeping right
rest in peace grandma she lived a long
full life but too much coke and heroin
will do that to you let this be a lesson
to be learned some poor little boy will
find her just old rotten up oh man holy
[ __ ]
she's dead yet grandma
grandma grandma grandma
oh she really is it I thought it was a
prank okay well this has been dying
slowly really fun dying with you bros
and try not to die next time because I
need more beers